um this next story actually it's gonna
bring us back to New Orleans again Greg
it will Chad Kelly the Denver Broncos
rush backup quarterback was arrested on
the day that we taped here for a
criminal trespassing and you're right in
a story that reminds me a bit of a story
that you had in college Chad Kelly was
found in a home which he did not own
apparently amoebae breeded mumbling
incoherently by the owner of the house
who promptly hit him with a piece of a
vacuum cleaner he called the police he
got drunk blacked out walked into a
stranger's house sat down next to her on
the couch and just heard mumbling to
himself which is holy didn't attack he
wasn't looking for anything he just went
to sit down and have a conversation and
most importantly he was dressed as a
cowboy like not it not a Dallas Cowboy a
full-blown no like a scarf around the
neck yeah he came from von Miller's
players only Halloween party it was
pretty easy to piece all this together
cuz the house was literally next door to
where von Miller was having this annual
players only party mhm this leads to
this is what reminded me of I'm gonna
tell the story because we're running out
of time
sophomore year of college I got invited
to a date party I was a sorority formal
or semi-formal I had to wear a tuxedo I
remember that and it was open bar those
things were open bar and I had no money
so open bar meant like you need to get
your fill and I blackout drunk
you could totally black out and they're
trying to take me home I've like ruined
the party for my friends my date was
sober because she was on medication at
the time and so his totally sober
driving us home and she's like Anthony
Witte live I think their friends want to
go out but they've got to drop me drop
me off at home first and I would only
give two answers they said I would
either say 5,000 Las Vegas Boulevard
which is not a thing in New Orleans or I
would say titty city and they kept they
got a note in at one point at a stop
sign you would often say you're the
mayor of titties I'm here of to City and
then I jumped out of the car to stop
sign and just ran away and they were
like chased after me couldn't get me and
just left and apparently I just walked
up to what I thought was my house and
tried to get in the front door
and they wouldn't let me in so I sat
down on a porch swing and I come to I
don't remember I the last thing I
remember is a date party and then I come
to an I'm on a porch swing and there's a
cop car lights flashing in front of me
and as the cop cars walking up and I'm
dressed in the tux so the cops like
what's going on and he walks up in his
woman jump runs out her brows and starts
screaming at me I don't know what I had
said I think was just scared someone
trying to get in the house yeah man
screaming at me and the cops like it's
okay I got it I got it takes me and this
is like where do you live and just drop
me off at home when I wake up the next
day and I'm not sure how I got home I
kind of remember a cop but I'm like huh
and then I call my date and she's like
here's what he did and then like two
nights later the cop comes back to our
house
and it's like hey this woman has filed a
complaint against me so I need to
interview you about it and I was like
dude I was wasted I don't know what I
was doing he's like no no no you were
you had something to drink and you were
confused is that clear
and I was like uh-huh he's like sign
this and then I never heard about it
again so if you're gonna get blackout
drunk and walk into someone's house
don't dress up like a cowboy dressed in
a tuxedo all right one week after we
talked about Aaron Hernandez being back
in the news another former NFL player
convicted for murder Rae Carruth the
former Ruth Carolina Panther walked out
of prison this week after serving 19
years in the murder of Cherica Adams who
was his fiancee and the mother to his
unborn child at the time of the murder
he was convicted of conspiracy to murder
he's changed his name in the meantime
he's now ray Wiggins and he is a free
man okay
here's that here's the question
everybody wants to know which team means
a wide receiver hmm where's he gonna go
Greg
this has got Patriots written all over
it I guess he Belichick taking a chance
being like you know what went you want
to win you gotta listen to my rules I
could see the Raiders taking them you
know the Raiders need some help if al
Davis was alive or break Ruth's fiance
was alive I could see him playing for
the Raiders feels like a Cowboys type a
pickup yeah they
Ashi get some popcorn just like a press
conference just like headlines you know
New Orleans I think they're always
looking for receivers with an edge do
you think do you think Rick Ruth has
lost a step
it can't help I mean you do have a lot
of time to work out in in jail 19 years
is a long time it is there's a long time
but he was a talent his career cut short
just three years into it so he has fresh
legs yeah that's true he does have fresh
legs and I think he's like I mean it's
probably gained some sort of some sort
of wisdom you know need some sort of
life wisdom that you can only get by
killing the mother of your unborn child
Greg do you think even though he waited
three seasons do you think that he you
think he's a hall-of-famer you think
he's got what it takes maybe not a first
rounder but I mean when he gets out when
he gets the veterans committee a veteran
I think he needs to be somewhere in that
gold jacket I think he needs to put up
more stats like you know they lately
they've been letting some players in
like Terrell Davis who kind of have a
short but really brilliant peak so
they're they're being more open to that
but generally they're more into the guys
with long careers kind of compiler types
mm-hmm he was like he was like a candle
that just burned brightly what would you
say was the best thing he ever did in
his career I think I've got my pick but
what do you think what do you think was
the was the best thing he ever did like
was it like a touchdown it was like a
good catch like a helmet catch kind of
thing that he did or was it just the his
third season definitely his production
picked up like he was a first-round pick
27th overall pick in the draft didn't
really produce too much and started
started to make some strides the NFL you
know is keeping close tabs on this if
you are a fan and there were at least
four fans on Monday when he was released
from jail that tried to buy a ray
Carruth Jersey yeah if you do in the NFL
shop and you're not allowed to do if he
didn't get you Rae Carruth Jersey before
he got released from prison they're not
getting these Fairweather fans who were
just jumping on the bandwagon now I'll
tell you here's the biggest question
from me if you're gonna let Rae Carruth
back into the NFL here's the only thing
I want answered the most important thing
is he going to stand for the national
anthem
[Music]
you